so David there are questions first of
all you directed four of the Harry
Potter films one of the most iconic
amazing franchises of all time and then
you take on this challenge does it feel
any different to you does it feel like a
different challenge - no it's an
extension of Joe's universe in a very
exciting way and it's a lot of the
things that we love about the Harry
Potter world but it's got a whole new
set of characters a whole new set of
rules and it's set in New York in 1926
so it takes her universe further in a
much more exciting and adventurous way
there are incredible beasts in the
trailer and this is a crowd that's going
to want details about the beasts
anything you can tell us about that
we've got a host we got a whole ray of
beasts that Eddie looks after in the in
his magical suitcase we've got this
little thing called an if ler that's
into a sort of treasure amort lap that's
a sort of pesky rat like creature a demo
guys which is an ape-like creature who
can appear and disappear at will and
these amazing amazing serpent like
creatures called kameez and these armies
can sort of change say size and shape so
they could be here on the tabletop next
to this bottle about this big or they
could fill this entire Hall and there's
some of our beasts all right now Eddie
this film is set in a new place new time
they're gonna be Easter eggs for fans
I'm told you comment on that at all no
comment
I'm sweating with excitement from just
running around Hall H III I don't think
I've even heard that question always
nice to have you run around a Hall Hall
H in what looks to be a heavy sweater in
San Diego in the 90s what would you sit
down and answer questions I like the way
they've laid this out for you
but yeah I just I was told that there
were Easter eggs in the film where there
may be Easter eggs I don't know if you
can comment on that okay there are eggs
I had the extraordinary excitement of
seeing like there's a Lego figure a Lego
figure that got me like more excited
than I've been since I was about 5 so
I'm sure there will be mr. eggs alright
this is for all the the
anyone on the panel who wants to comment
about their their characters in you know
in the film and talk about portraying
those characters and anything you want
to say go for it nope well there you go
was it exciting to jump into JK
Rowling's world anyone who wants to take
that one this is yes it was incredible I
mean who's a Harry Potter fan in here so
imagine that you think that that world
is done and then you get to walk into it
you get to be a part of a brand new
world but it's set in 1926 in New York
and the American version I mean can you
imagine that it's like getting your
hogwarts lettered way late in the game
but you're still getting it you get your
letter now Dan you play I think the only
non magical character who has a central
role in the film what's that like well
lonely it's yeah you know Han Solo
wasn't a Jedi it's a really good point
I'm a magical person in real life I was
thinking you know today's day and age
that would be cool it's just a little
sore cuz he didn't get a wand like
everybody else did yeah roll on Dendy
hang around there's like 20,000 of them
here someone will sell you their wand
for much more than they should that's
how these people are I think where it
takes some Q&A from the audience I
believe and I think that's gonna go just
as it always has we're gonna look this
way and I bet someone's in a costume
that's the way things go here let's have
the lights come up and we'll do some Q&A
and it's that guy again Hey the busy day
for you your highness I'm sorry there's
10,000 people in this room how do you
get to questions
it's good to be the king it's it's okay
they'll be back I'm just thrilled to be
in the room where it happens so I'm a
costume designer and oh really
it's good to see you don't take your
work home with you I want to dress all
of you calling that what is my idol a
better word and I want to know what it
was like working with her because I want
to be on that level someday anyway there
was this random oh it's gonna appear in
the floor and is gonna disappear and be
dead and got to be a drone sir H be even
bigger there are some moments where you
look around and I just there are these
you know all the extras so specific it's
so beautiful and you know from from
where I was standing at each one of them
looked like him you know like an action
figure that I just was like pick them up
off you know and take them home they
just looked so perfect you know she
she's incredible she she has a way of
making you look great and and just
perfectly fitting into the story you
know she's completely consumed by what
she does when every single character in
the film whether it's a leading
character or supporting character
somebody who may be a day player nothing
gets in front of the camera without her
checking at first um I were I have a
coat along kind of something that kind
of felt like a cloak but it wasn't a
cloak
but I dare anyone to tell me it wasn't a
toke but anyway I had this I had this
really beautiful long black cloud coke
coke and and she had she had two
versions of it and the shoulders were
there was maybe a quarter an inch of
difference between the two versions in
the shoulders and based on where the
camera was going to be positioned and to
her eye the aesthetic of the co change
dramatically enough that she had those
two that seems like a small detail but
for her to have that level of attention
and care what the process was amazing
amazing to be around and she was just so
imaginative she's the ultimate gangster
yeah she looks at you and she's like she
already knows your sizes it's completely
next level so you feel like a piece of
meat yeah she is what he's saying it's
not about you but you're kind of okay
with us she makes everything as well or
she has everything made so just down to
the smallest detail like our shoes were
made for us
everything was handcrafted and and done
in a very beautiful way so you never
feel like you're wearing anything that's
that's modern everything that we wore
felt like it was from this other world
and as an actor I think that really
influences how you how you feel because
you feel like you're immersed in a
different universe fully and then also
with the sets and everything the point
where she even made period underwear
available which is not to wear but I
stole some of that I still have my
period and I'm rocking the 1924 today
you